[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم واهلا بكم تعقد في الكويت
القمه السنويه لدول مجلس التعاون الخليجيه
الست وسط جمله من القضايا الداخليه
والتطورات الاقليم
التي يتعين على دول المجلس ايجاد سبل
للتعامل معها نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش
في
محورين حجم التحديات الداخليه امام
المنظومه الخليجيه خاصه مع بروز الخلافات
بشان فكره
الاتحاد ومدى قدره دول الخليج على ايجاد
اليه مشتركه للتعامل مع القضايا الاقليميه
واهمها الملف
الايراني
في ظل تطورات اقليميه متسارعه تتزامن مع
تحديات داخليه متعدده تاتي قمه الكويت
لدول مجلس التعاون الخليجي القاده
المجتمعون يتعين عليهم الاجابه على عدد من
الاسئله لدى الشارع الخليجي تتعلق
بالسياسه والدفاع والاقتصاد خاصه بعد
الخلاف العلني فيما يتعلق بمساله الاتحاد
كما يتعين عليهم التعامل مع متغيرات
اقليميه فرضها الامر الواقع اهمها الاتفاق
الايراني الاخير مع
الغرب قمه لدول مجلس التعاون الخليجي في
الكويت تجتمع الدول الست على وقع عدم
اجماع بشان بعض القضايا مواقف بعض الدول
وتصريحات مسؤوليها قبيل القمه اوضحت ان
المجلس ليس هذه الايام صوتا واحدا في كل
الملفات فالم قرح السعودي الجديد القديم
بشان الاتحاد الخليجي مرفوض بشكل علني من
قبل سلطنه عمان وفي حال اعتماده هددت مسقط
بالانسحاب من المجلس الذي تاسس عام
1981 دول اخرى تعارض الفكره بلغه اقل حده
من العمانيين تبين المواقف بين السلطنه
والمملكه العربيه السعوديه بشان ايران جلي
الاتفاق التمهيدي الذي توصلت اليه طهران
مع مجموعه 5د واح في جنيف توج بعد محادثات
سريه بين الامريكيين وال
برعايه سلطنه عمان حسب تسريبات صحفيه بعين
غير راضيه تنظر الرياض الى اي تقارب خليجي
مع ايران في الوقت الحالي على الاقل حتى
وان تضمن البيان الختامي لقمه الكويت
ترحيبا باسم جميع الدول المجلس باتفاق جنف
الاخير بشان البرنامج النووي الايراني
فذلك لن يبدد مخاوف فريق وبراغماتية
فليس سرا ان دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي
تختلف بشان مدى الدعم المقدمه لتيارات
المعارضه السوريه الوضع في مصر ما بعد
الانقلاب على حكم الاخوان اظهر تبينا في
وجهات النظر بين الدول الست صحيح ان هجس
الامن في منطقه الخليج قاسم مشترك ولكن
تختلف درجته واسلوب تحقيقه من بلد الى اخر
تامل السعوديه ان تحقق حلم الاتحاد الذي
تعتبره الان ضرور
وليس طرفا بيد انها تتشبث فيه في وقت تحرس
فيه اكثر من دوله في مجلس التعاون الخليجي
على التغريد ولو جزئيا خارج سرب
الرياض موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع ضيوفنا من
بيروت سيف بن
هاشل المسكري نائب الامين العام الاسبق
للشؤون السياسيه بمجلس التعاون الخليجي
ومن الكويت معنا كل من الدكتور عايد
المناع الاكاديمي والاعلامي الكويتي وجمي
الذيابي الكاتب والصحفي السعودي نبدا مع
ضيفنا من الكويت الدكتور عيد المناع ونود
ان نعرف في الواقع دكتور كيف تابعت
انعكاسات
الخلافات الخليجيه وتحديدا ما سمعناه
بخصوص الرفض العماني الصريح بخصوص موضوع
الاتحاد الخليجي كيف انعكست على اجواء
القمه لا شك اولا اسعد الله اوقاتكم وسهلا
واسعد الله اوقات ضيوفك الكرم
لا شك بانه
يعني حصلت مفاجاه من الموقف العماني وين
كانت عمان يمكن سابقا لمحت الى هذا الجانب
لكن منذ يعني منتدى المنامه قبل ايام اتضح
ان عمان لها موقف مناوئ
لقيام الاتحاد الخليجي الذي دعت
اليه المملكه العربيه السعوديه و بالتالي
يعني عمان كدوله مؤسسه لمجلس
التعاون هذا الموقف الصريح
والعلني يثير اكثر من علامه استفهام قد لا
تكون عمان هي الوحيده التي لا ترغب بقيام
الاتحاد الخليجي او ان يك لكنها الوحيده
التي عبرت عن ذلك بصراحه نود ان نعرف
الاسماء
الاخرى والله الاسماء الاخرى طبعا احنا
يعني ربما يكون كثيرين لديهم تح ضات لكن
واضح ان عمان كانت يعني الاكثر وضوحا في
هذا
الاتجاه ربما لانه البعض يعتقد وانا اعتقد
انه يعني مبكر نسبيا موضوع الاتحاد
لان الاسس التي ينبغي ان يقوم عليها لم
تقم الى الان اتفهم
تماما مبادره خادم الحرمين الشريفين لانه
قد يكون اتخاذ القرار السياسي باقامه
الاتحاد اجدى من التسلسل الذي ربما تفكر
فيه عمان ودول اخرى وهو انه يكون
هناك اتحاد يعني
مصرفي سوق خليجيه مشتركه سنعود الى كل هذه
دكتور عايد دعنا نتحول الى ضيفنا من
الكويت ايضا قبل ان نستطلع الراي العماني
ضيفنا من الكويت الكاتب الصحفي السعودي
جميل الذيابي سيد جميل سمعت لعل الوقت ليس
مناسبا او انه من المبكر ربما ولعل عمان
قالت صراحه ما يضمره كثيرون غيرها في دول
مجلس التعاون الخليجي السعوديه كيف ترى كل
ذلك يعني ما موقفها تحديدا من هذا الخلاف
حول فكرتها المتعلقه بالاتحاد
الخليجي طبعا احيي ضيوفك
ايضا طبعا السعوديه اطلق قط فكرته هذه
الفكره
ليست من من فراغ عندما قالها خادم الحرمين
الشريفه الا انها ايضا تنص عليها الماده
الرابعه من النظام
الاساسي
لمجلس مجلس التعاون
الخليجي نعرف
بانه مجلس التعاون الخليجي الخليجي منذ ان
تاسس في في مطلع الثمانينات والمنطقه
الخليجيه او الدول السته الخليجيه
تمر بتحديات امنيه تحديات امنيه كبيره
مرورا بالحرب حرب الخليج الاولى بين
العراق وايران ومن ثم غزو والكويت
وايضا احتلال العراق من قوى امريكا وايضا
التحديات الموجوده الان وطبعا ظهر ظهر
الايراني بعد بعد سقوط يعني اعذرني سنعود
الى كل هذه النقاط لكن اود ان اعرف
السعوديه كيف
نحك الاتحاد هل بلك تر الفكره ارج ام انها
اجهضت لا المملكه العربيه السعوديه لم
ترجي هذه الفكره والفكره عازمه عليها
عازمه فع التهديد
الانح
اء دين
لو سمحتي دعيني اكمل فكرتي لو سمحتي
المملكه العربيه السعوديه تريد لهذا
الاتحاد ان ان ان يقام كيف يقام متى
الزمان والمكان هذا الامر طبعا سيتحدد من
خلال قمه خاصه س حدد المكان في الرياض لكن
الزمان لم يحدد عمليه عمليه اللجان
التي اجتمعت في وقت سابق مرتين او ثلاث في
الرياض ومن ثم كانت الاراء والافكار
الموجوده من ذوي الخبرات من الذين عملوا
في مجلس التعاون الخليجي او من
القانونيين اغلبيه دول مجلس التعاون او
المنظومه الخليجيه كانوا مع فكره الاتحاد
هناك بعض
بعض الاسئله هناك بعض التساؤلات بعض
الاسئله وبعض التساؤلات دع نحاول ان
نستفسر من
ضيفنا من السياده ساعود اليك طبعا دعنا
فقط وقد سمعنا وجهتي نظر من داخل د المجلس
التعاون الخليجي نود ان نعرف ثلاث لاءات
رفعتها السلطنه لا للاتحاد لا للعمله
الخليجيه الموحده ولا لتوسعه قوات درع
الجزيره الا تهدد بذلك سلطنه عمان بتفكيك
منظومه العمل الخليجي
ككل ه السلام عليكم مساك الله بالخير اذا
كان السؤال اذا كان السؤال موجه لي انا
اعتقد الموقف العماني في هذه اللاءات كانت
موجوده ليس اليوم فقط وانما لفتره طويله
ولكن هذه المره هذه اللاءات كانت اكثر
وضوحا من المرات الماضيه ا وخاصه فيما
يتعلق بالاتحاد اظني معالي وزير الوزير
المسؤول عن الشؤون الخارجيه قالها بصراحه
ان عمان لا تمانع من قيام الاتحاد ولكن لا
ترى نفسها ان تكون عضوا في هذا هذا هذا
الاتحاد وهذا ليس تهديد بقدر ما هو موقف
يعني ممكن الاتحاد يكون ب من دولتين او
يمكن من الخمس الدول الباقيه او يمكن لا
هذا كلام مهم سامحني عذرا السيد سيف بس
لكن يجب ان نتوقف عنده هل معنى ذلك بان
عمان تعلن صراحه انسحابها من منظومه
الاتحاد او التكتل او دول مجلس التعاون
الخليجي وهي بذلك ربما لديها توجه جديد
خاصه ونحن نعلم جميعا ان نستذكر ما حدث
على اراضيها بخصوص الاتفاق النووي
الغربي او على الاقل
تسريبات في في فيما يتعلق فيما يتعلق
بالاتحاد كان الموقف واضحا جدا بانها لن
تكون او ل يكون لها مقعد في الاتحاد اما
اذا استمر مجلس التعاون بهذه الحاله فعمان
مثل ما كانت التزمت بكل
قرارات المجلس سابقا ستلتزم اما في ما
يتعلق
بال قوات درع الجزيره فايضا لها راي عمان
بانه ما هو
دواعي قوه درع الجزيره في مرحله نحن على
الاقل في م في دول المجلس نمر بمرحله
اسلام هل المقصود بانه هناك هذه القوه درع
الجزيره تكون موجهه لجهه معينه ما هو القص
منها وخاصه وخاصه ان دول المجلس رفضت فكره
تقويه تقويه المنظومه العسكريه او
المنظومه الامنيه سنه 91 نعم سيد سيفي سنه
يعني الى حد الان اعذرني فقط نود ان نفهم
المشاهد الكريم لم تشرح لنا
لماذا عمان ابدت هذا الرفض الصريح على غير
عادتها بخصوص موضوع
الاتحاد لا لانه فوجئت بهذا الطرح بشكل
قوي وبالتالي فما كان امامها الا ان تقول
رايها صراحه لانه الموضوع مطروح يعني منذ
سنوات عديده وهي ايضا كانت قد تبنته في
مراحله السابقه حتى قبل السعوديه اسمحي لي
اسمحيلي اسمحيلي لا لا هي تبنت مشروع
التعاون الامني والاقتصادي في المنطقه
ولكن لن تتبنى مشروع اتحاد فهذا الاتحاد
له مفهوم وله سياساته وه اسسه فحتى الان
غير واضح وبالتالي فحتى لا ن
تطيع يعني عمان لا تلتزم باي قرار فمن
الافضل ان تقول من البدايه بانها غير
قادره على الالتزام بمشروع الاتحاد واضح
تماما دعني اتحول الان للسيد عايد المناع
دكتور عايد مرايك في هذا الكلام واين يضع
منظومه العمل الخليجي كيف يؤثر
عليها انا كنت اتمنى عليك انه انت تطرحي
على صديقنا العزيز
[موسيقى]
المسكري هل هذا الموقف العماني مؤقت
ومرتبط في فتره زمنيه معينه
لتحضير كل الامكانيات ليقوم الاتحاد ام
انه موقف نهائي لا يقبل
حقيقه البيان التاسيسي لمجلس التعاون
والذي كانت عمان حاضر فيه وعضو مؤسس اشار
بوضوح ان الهدف النهائي هو وحده هذه
المنظومه عمان كانت صريحه عفوا سيد سيد
عايد المى ضيفنا صريح وعمان كانت صريحه
الان وفق ما ذكره ضيفنا من بيروت هل يمكن
ان نتخيل اتحادا خليجيا دون
عمان لا لا ممكن يكون بدون عمان وممكن
الحقيقه يكون باقل عدد لا مش اشكاليه لكن
الحقيقه سيكون مؤلما ان تخرج عمان الدوله
المؤسسه والعضوه اساسي بدون مبررات جوهريه
يعني ما الذي يمنع كل مبررات الوحده قائمه
لدول مجلس التعاون وبالتالي ما الذي يمنع
ان يكون هناك اتحاد ان يكون الوقت مبكرا
او ان يكون هناك مطالب معينه مثلا انا
ككويتيين
ان اتعرف على الجواب ضيفنا من بيروت السيد
سيف بن هاشم المسك بس اسمحيلي بس هذه انه
المشاركه الشعبيه ضروريه لانه الديمقراطيه
اللي يتمتع فيها في الكويت نسبيا اتمنى ان
لا افقدها على الاطلاق واعتقد انها
مطلب اجابه نحول السؤال لضيفنا من بيروت
سيد سيف طيب شكرا شكرا دكتور المناع
الحقيقه انا اتفق معك بانه قضيه الاتحاد
هي ليست مساله سهله وان اتحاد الشعوب هو
المطلب اساسي اعتقد شعوب المنطقه كلها
ترغب ان ترى هذا المشروع اما ان يكون
اتحاد
يعني فوقي وبالتالي فكل
كل ما ما
تم هو طرح سؤال هل هو موقف اني ولحظي ام
انه موقف ثابت لا رجعه
فيه انا انا في تصوري انه هذا موقف ثابت
وليس
مؤقت
بكل امانه واعتقد الكويت انا بس انا بس
اريد اعلق نقطه واحده بانه الكويت استمرت
اكثر من 20 سنه ترفض اتفاقيه امنيه ام
يعني وبالتالي فهي مثلا مسائ اسباب
دستوريه نعم من الواضح ان الخلافات ستنتقل
حتى الى الى هنا في الاستديو الخلافات
التي باتت للاسف كبيره بين دول مجلس
التعاون الخليجيه تحول الى الكويت مره
اخرى وضيفنا السييد جميل الذيابي هي هو
موقف ثابت كما قال ضيفنا من الكويت سيد
سيف ازاءه السعوديه كيف تنظر لمشروعها
ومسيره التعاون الخليجي اجمالا في غياب
عمان طبعا انا اتمنى على كل دول الخليج
العربيه وخصوصا المملكه العربيه السعوديه
بان لا تفقد الامل في في موضوع انضمام
سلطنه عمان الى هذا الاتحاد الخليجي
لاسباب عده اولا المصير واحد والاراده
لابد ان تكون ايضا واحده المملكه العربيه
السعوديه صاحبه المبادره
والمقترح وهذا المبادره والمقترح تنبع
اصلا من اصل النظام الاساسي لمجلس التعاون
الخليجي
لذلك سلطنه عمان عندما اطلقت الثلاث لاءات
سواء للعمله او لدرع الجزيره او ايضا
لموضوع الاتحاد الخليجي هذه لا يمكن ان
تكون عضو في منظومه واحده ومن ثم تطلق هذه
اللاءات فجاه بدون ان تقدم ايضاحات او
تقدم اجابه على التساؤلات هذه التساؤلات
انا اعتقد كل دول الخليج الخمسه الاخرى
لابد ان تدخل في صلب
ومتن القرار القرار القرار العماني ومن ثم
ومن ثم تتدخل بما يمكن ان يؤثر ايضا على
بقاء السلطنه في
الخليجيه الموافقه المبدئيه على هذا الطرح
نعم ننتقل الان واستسمح ضيوفي الكرام
سنعود طبعا ننتقل الى فاصل قصير نواصل
بعدها النقاش عن مدى قدره دول الخليج على
ايجاد اليه مشتركه للتعامل مع القضايا
الاقليميه واهمها الملف الايراني نرجو ان
تبقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا في هذه
الحلقه التي تناقش تحديات المطروحه امام
قاده دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي في قمه
الكويت نتحول الى الكويت مباشره ضيفنا من
هناك
دكتور عايد المناع دكتور عايد الان الى اي
مدى باعتقادك يمكن فعلا تجاوز هذه
الخلافات ايجاد اليه مشتركه ارضيه مشتركه
ان شئنا خاصه امام التحديات الكبيره
المشتركه ايضا التي تواجه دول الخليج
اقليميا ولنبدا بالملف الايراني لعله
الملف الاكثر
الحاحا يعني اولا انا اعتقد انه ممكن
نتجاوز موضوع
يعني
زوبعه
الاتحاد بتاجيل الموضوع واعتقد ان وزير
الدوله الكويت لشؤون مجلس الوزراء اعلن
ذلك انه ممكن يؤجل هذا الموضوع وبالتاكيد
انه سيترك لمزيد من
المناقشات عندي اطمئنان ان
عمان يعني لن لن يكون من مصلحتها ولا ترغب
جديا بان تبتعد عن منظومه مجلس التعاون
ربما الامور وقتيه
وكما تعلمون السياسه العمانيه متكتمه يعني
ليست يعني مثل بعض السياسات واضحه كثيرا
انا اعتقد انه قضيه الملف النووي الايراني
تهم دول مجلس التعاون ككل والاتفاق
الايراني الغربي كشف بانه هناك امور تدار
من خلف ظهر مجلس التعاون وان كان يعني من
حق الدول ان يكون لها سريه الا انه نحن
طرف مباشر في هذه المنطقه
وحقيقه رفض ايران للاقتراح القطري بان
تكون دول الخليج طرف
في الحوارات القادمه ما بين الايران
والخ ز واح يشير بكل اسف الى ما يمكن ان
يسمى بعنجهية
نقطه مهمه دعني اتحول بها الى ضيفنا من
بيروت السيد سيف هذه النقطه التي بدات
ربما كشوكه في حلق الدول الخليجيه ان تجري
مفاوضات على الارض العمانيه على مرمى حجر
من هذه الدول مفاوضات بين ايران وا
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ولا تخبرها لا
من باب اللياقه اللباقه حسن الجوار سميها
ما شئت يعني وسمعنا تلك النبره ايضا في
صوت الدكتور المناع لماذا نعم اسمح لي
اسمحي لي يا اخي واسمح لي لاخ المناع لا
اعتقد عمان كما يقال عنها انه تغرد خارج
الصرب واذا كان الدور اللي قامت فيه من
اجل من اجل التوصل الى نوع من الاتفاق بين
القوى بين ايران والدول الغربيه لانه
الطرفين كانوا هم يعني بحاجه الى من يسهل
عمليه اللقاءات وعمليه المفاوض
واما وعمان لم تكن طرف مباشر في عمليه
المفاوضات وبالتالي فيجب ان لا تحمل
الامور اكثر مما تح تتحمل صحيح الدور
العماني كان دور ايجابي وهذا اللي مصلحه
في في اعتقادنا او
اعتقاد اصحاب القرار في عمان بان هذه
لمصلحه المنطقه لانه عمليه التوت يعني كيف
من مصلحه المنطقه وهناك من يرى بان من
اولى ثمراته هذا الموقف العماني الذي يعني
يستهجن الخليجيون بقرارها الخروج من صلب
هذا الجسم الذي يربطه اكثر مما يفرقه اخت
اخ اختي الكريمه عمان لم يعني قعد بكل
صراحه اذا كان التوجه لتاسيس الاتحاد فلا
ترى نفسها في هذا الاتحاد لانها غير قادره
على
الالتزام بما يعني يتضمنه قرارات قيام
الاتحاد اما اذا استمر استمرت منظومه
المجلس فهي ملتزمه كما التزمت سابقا وت
تدفع بالعمل المشترك نحو الامام سواء
العمل الامني او الاقتصادي او السياسي
وبالتالي فيجب ان لا تحمل بعض الاشياء
اكثر مما تتحمل
يعني ايه للاسف لم يبقى معنا الكثير من
الوقت سنكرس لضيفنا من الكويت السيد جميل
البي سمعت ما قاله ضيفنا من عمان الاتفاق
الايراني الغربي يعني خرج بيان من دول
مجلس التعاون الخليجي ترحب لكن ما في
القلب في القلب كما يقال هذا الاتفاق في
نهايه الامر يصب فعلا في مصلحه دول الخليج
ام
لا طبعا
دعيني اعرج على نقطه ذكرها الاخ المسكري
من بيروت وهي ان عمان اذا ظلت المنظومه
كمجلس ظل موجوده في حال الاتحاد ستنسحب
ومثل ما عرفنا في التصريحات
السابقه لا يمكن ان تقبل دول مجلس التعاون
الخليجي بعضو في مجلس التعاون او او في
المنظومه الخليجيه يغرد ايضا عكس مصالح
هذه هذه المنظومه او مجلس التعاون سلطنه
عمان عندما
استضافت التفاوض بين واشنطن وطهران لم
تبلغ الدول الخليجيه ولم تبلغ دوله خليجيه
واحده وهذه اشكاليه ومعناها هناك ازمه ثقه
بينها وبين ايضا الاعضاء في مجلس التعاون
الخليجي يجب ان يكون هناك ايضا التعاون
التكامل التنسيق موجود وهذه من ابجديات
ايضا مجلس التعاون الخليجي الشيء الاخر
وهو ان ايران ايران كل ما تفعله ايران في
المنطقه هو ضد المصالح الخليجيه بالدرجه
الاولى عندما تعمل في سوريا او في بيروت
او في اليمن او في تدخل في بعض الدول
الخليجيه من تحريض
ومحاوله محاوله بث فتنه و محاوله لاثاره
بعض الامور التي لا لا يمكن ان ان تاتي
بالاستقرار الى المنطقه يعني هذه
الاشكاليات ضد المصالح الخليجيه بالدرجه
الاولى دول الخليج اليوم لديها هاجس امني
هذا الهاجس منذ ان تاسس هذا المجلس لذلك
يجب ان تكون
سلطنه
عمان معاون
وايضا دافع
لعمليه الاستقرار للمنطقه ليس بالتعاون مع
ليس بالتعاون مع ايران وعلى سبيل على سبيل
عزل الدول الخليجيه الاخرى ملف معنيه في
هذه الدول الخليجيه لكون المفاعل النووي
الايراني والبرنامج النووي الايراني يؤثر
يؤثر على العواصم الخليجيه اكثر من تاثيره
على طهران اشكرك جزيل الشكر سيد جميل
الكاتب الصحفي السعودي كنت معنا من الكويت
نشكر ايضا من الكويت الدكتور عيد المناع
الاكاديمي والاعلامي الكويتي جزي الشكر
ونشكر ضيفنا من بيروت السيد سيف بن هاشل
المسكري نائب الامين العام الاسبق للشؤون
السياسيه بمجلس التعاون الخليجي شكرا
جزيلا لكل ضيوفنا وبهذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه
من برنامج ما وراء الخبر نلتقي باذن الله
في قراءه جديده في ما وراء خبر جديد
السلام
عليكم